[Musique]
avec nico l'artiste qui est formatrice
et coach en éducation je le disais tout
à l'heure des parents vous envoyer des
enfants aussi depuis 1968 des enfants
tyran vraisemblablement aussi j'ai envie
de vous demander une école avant qu'on
voit en images un petit peu ce qu'est un
enfant tirant ce qu'il existe un test
pour savoir si son enfant est un tyran
un enfant tirant alors poussé à
l'extrême effectivement enfin ça peut
être une forme de pathologie en fait
hein c'est pas de ça dont on parle un
mois je parle d'enfants effectivement
qui ont une difficulté à envisager à la
frustration
c'est à dire que pour eux c'est très
compliqué il m'a simplement très
concrètement dire que vous recevez des
parents des enfants oui parce que vous
avez une feuille programmes d'ordinateur
quelque chose que non pour dire
attention votre enfant à mon avis un
enfant tyran n'en ont d'ailleurs on
utilise rarement le terme
en soi c'est à dire que l'on fait
remarquer effectivement aux parents
puisqu'on et pape sy nous on est coach a
que le comportement de l'enfant
effectivement est aujourd'hui
problématique clairement un enfant qui
vient et on essaie pour surtout pour des
promus scolaires et qu'ils ne se des
scotchs pas de la maman c'est à dire qui
est agrippée à elle et à aucun moment
effectivement il va la lâcher pour pape
c'est l'histoire c'est souvent la maman
qui emmène les enfants
il ya une problématique un petit
effectivement qu'il trouve pas sa place
dans sa classe ou la maîtresse a
convoqué les parents ou au collège qui a
des difficultés d insolence
on peut effectivement un moment donné
s'inquiéter on va en parler d'autant
qu'il ya deux parents qui sentent le
côté de voeux qui sont très attentifs
vous l'avez remarqué tfl et nicolas et
vous tous aussi et les amis grands
parents qui sont là mais d'abord
l'enfant en tirant qu'est ce que c'est
précisément en images ça donne quoi ça
donne ça regardez j'en peux plus arthur
fait la loi est venue en dessus on a
fabriqué un enfant sur ans à chery notre
époque at elle un problème avec
l'autorité
aujourd'hui 85 % des français
considèrent que les parents ne sont pas
assez sévères et les psychologues voit
débarquer dans leur cabinet de plus en
plus de parents d
ni face à leurs enfants tir en colère
terrible refus d'autorité menaces
chantages violence et enfants s'y rend
et prêt à tout pour exercer son pouvoir
sans partage certains parents sont même
battus alors comment expliquer ce
phénomène est bien dans la plupart des
cas il s'agit bien de carence éducative
les parents qui n'osent pas affirmer
leur autorité poser des limites de peur
que leurs enfants ne les aime plus créé
chez lui une incapacité à supporter la
frustration et au bout du compte une
insécurité l'enfant tyran est en fait en
pleine détresse parents arrêtez de vous
culpabiliser ou de vous dire que ça va
passer
si vous ne vous sentez pas capable comme
le conseillent les psys de prendre de la
distance et d'affichés de l'indifférence
aux crises de votre petit dictateur
aller vite consulter avant que toute
votre famille il explose car la tyrannie
infantile peut parfois être le symptôme
de troubles psychiatriques qu'on
qualifie de top trouble oppositionnel
avec provocation
bref parents non l'amour ne résout pas
tout cela dit l'amour c'est quand même
nécessaire pour permettre à l'enfant
grandit on va pas se le cacher tu t'es
fait malgré tout nicolas et est ce que
vous pensez de ce que vous dites mais
c'est tout à fait ça en fait une terme
de carence éducative ne faudrait pas que
les parents en fait se culpabiliser elle
les parents pour ce faire le mieux
possible
en fait ils sont convaincus que leur
système éducatif est le meilleur
simplement je pense que quelque chose
qui réalisent pas c'est que très souvent
on a tous des carences autant que nos
parents aient pu nous aimer et comme je
suis parent je ne comble pas la petite
fille qui n'a pas reçu ce qu'elle aurait
aimé un et qu'elle veut donner à son
enfant
est ce que ça veut dire que le rêve de
tout parent finalement et donner à son
enfant ce dont on a manqué dans son
passé sans s'en rendre compte
oui et très souvent effectivement de ce
que les parents découvrent ça c'est
beaucoup plus simple en fait on ne
répare pas à part soi même
en fait ce que je peux me donner
aujourd'hui pour réparer ce que je n'ai
pas reçu mais il ya une dérive house
imagine que on m'a rien expliqué on m'a
pas écouté on avait fait à ses
compliments on a été sévère avec moi
donc je vais faire tout l'inversé
ok il ya deux jeunes parents qui sont à
côté de vous qu'est ce que vous faites
concrètement tiphaine facebook est maman
d'eric et
suzanne d'entre vos enfants font une
crise c'est pas forcément des enfants
tyran mais il faut une crise qu'est ce
que vous faites votre recette à vous
c'est quoi des points mais moi dans mon
état de fatigue
non je sais que il paraît que
normalement il faudrait rester calmes et
aller plutôt vers pas forcément vers la
punition mais plutôt vers peut-être le
câlin 6e ils sont dans un état de stress
total parce que le stress plus le stress
que ce stress ça n'arrêterai pas la
crise mais comme souvent c'est plus la
punition et le stress qui s'ajoute au
stress votre avis qu'est-ce que vous
donnez comme conseils aux parents qui
viennent nous consulter régulier alors
lorsque ça atteint vraiment des
problématiques fortes parce que ça ne
touche pas que les parents ça touche la
fratrie aussi un donc et qui sont un
petit peu plus grands voiliers vers 6-7
ans c'est vraiment de leur montrer que
la vie de famille en fait ça fonctionne
tous ensemble et qu'à un moment donné
quand ils deviennent trop pénible eh
bien on les isole
enfin et c'est très souvent ce qui très
rapidement va donner des résultats
c'est à dire on leur demande d'aller
dans leur chambre et en fait la famille
montre qu' elle est joyeuse
1 oui goal for enfin cetera et l'enfant
se rend compte que et bien il sera
associé à la famille quand il est
capable de prendre une place acceptable
cela vivre m'arrêter si je me trompe
mais moi il me semble que le rôle des
parents c'est quand même d'éduquer les
enfants qu'il faut un moment fixé de
limites fixées des bornes c'est parce
qu'on en fixe pas assez qu'on fabrique
entre guillemets à un enfant tyran que
l'enfant devient tirons c'est ça je
pense si vous voulez que on est dans une
société et enfin s'est dit d'ailleurs
dans le reportage
le terme autorités fait énormément peur
mais et c'est dans tout dans tous les
univers
vous écrivez nous et dans un contenu de
formation puisque on forme aussi dans
les entreprises autorités immédiatement
nous dit oulala attendait il faut faire
attention en fait autorité c'est tel que
nous on le conçoit ses êtres hauteur du
c'est à dire que quand on tombe pas
ranger duc ex duce ré apprendre à mon
enfant elle aidera cessa l'étymologie du
terme
je suis convaincu que ce que je mets en
oeuvre est bon pour mon enfant je n'ai
pas de doute 0,883 383 pas de doute non
plus pour
ce monsieur qui est papa de deux enfants
il s'appelle tir il a souhaité vous
poser une question je propose de
l'écouter ça va nous intéresser tôt s'il
est question d'amour
écoutez être à l'écouté des besoins de
l'enfant est ce vraiment faire de lui un
enfant droit
je ne parle pas de respecter et d'être à
l'écouté de chacun du moindre de ses
désirs mais respecter ses besoins de
sommeil c'est besoin de rythme
chronobiologique que ses besoins de
repas est ce que c'est vraiment vraiment
en faire un enfant droit alors voilà
c'est une question qui doit être mise en
perspective au regard des besoins des
adultes et des besoins des enfants
merci thierry pour votre question à 0
805 383 383 alors si on a bien entendu
être à l'écouté des besoins de l'enfant
est ce que c'est vraiment faire de son
enfant à un enfant roi est ce que c'est
ce trop plein d'amour qui provoque à
l'enfant en tirant je pense si vous
voulez que lorsqu'on en arrive au stade
où je n'ai entendu dernièrement une
maman avec trois enfants qui dit le soir
je demande à chacun de mes enfants ce
qu'ils ont envie de manger un nom nous
la maman elle travaille toute la journée
quand elle rentre le soir elles ont peu
plus facile vu que je n'étais pas lé pa
ou services effectivement de ses enfants
il ya une vie de famille une vie de
partage les enfants ont besoin de
sommeil ils ont un besoin de sommeil
bien plus important que nous donc tout
dépend si effectivement le désir de la
famille et le partage on partage des
moments ensemble on vit des choses
ensemble
y'a papa qui est là qui dit rien depuis
tout à l'heure un nicolas papa de nolan
est est ce que de temps en temps pour
jouer quand même un petit peu le rôle de
papa c'est à dire on dit souvent que le
papa il a un peu plus ferme à pour plus
de fermeté
ça vous arrive franchement j'essaye bon
je sais comme de rester relativement zen
quand même mais de nous n'a surtout des
problèmes le soir au niveau du quatuor
leroyer baudot donc et c'est souvent là
que naît le droit des colères et c'est
vrai que ses charmes évidents de nos
conduisait comme on disait de mendoça
championnat
pascal c'est ça gérer la colère de son
fils de sa fille je donne un exemple
dernièrement une dame son petit refuse
de se laver les dents et pour l
électorat l unifa de façon oui génique
médicales et autres c'est important et
bien elle a vu le truc
elles minent julie musique d'un dessin
animé et quand langues
le gamin dans la musique alors qu'elle a
tout essayé donc ils vont en s'amusant
les halles deux échecs en france à
bruxelles 2 1
et là ils le font ensemble eh ben ça y
est ça marche
donc il ya des choses en fait il faut
aussi retrouver une forme de fantaisie
en fait de quand on est bien en fond je
pense qu'il ya des choses qu'on peut
partager au niveau effectivement des
limites à poser avec une forme de
fantaisie 0 805 383 383 je vous propose
maintenant d'écouter le témoignage de
noël à les professeurs des écoles les
parents qui ont une attitude trop
permissive avec leurs enfants les mettre
en difficulté car ils ne sont pas
habitués à affecter des règles à la
maison et ont donc plus de mal que les
autres à respecter le règlement de
l'école et aux règlements de la classe
les professeurs doivent alors insisté
sur les règles du bien vivre ensemble
et malheureusement il ya inévitablement
des conséquences sur les apprentissages
scolaires
l'apprentissage de la lecture de
l'orthographe et cetera exige de
l'enfant de la discipline et le respect
du code
merci novelli pour votre témoignage de
la alors un enfant tirant avec ses
parents ne l'est peut-être pas forcément
à l'extérieur du cocon familial des
néanmoins on comprend quand même votre
adresse qui vient d'être dit que
l'autorité pour un enfant tyran c'est
compliqué quels conseils vous pouvez
donner encore une fois aux parents
grands parents qui sont avec nous
vraiment effectivement de se mettre aux
quais déjà notre le papa et la maman
parce qu'alors le pire des cas de figure
et les enfants le sont très bien c'est
quand d'un côté efficace devant version
exactement 1 et que les parents soient
vraiment au quai sur ce qui fait partie
de la vie de la famille deuxième chose
fondamentale si je dis quelque chose je
me tiens il vaut mieux que je dise rien
à en l'occurrence par exemple souvent
privation des écrans pour les un peu
plus grand si je dis tu es privé d'écran
4 jours le deuxième jour je lâche pas je
pensais petite vie privée de télévision
elle laisse elle prend son chat est le
glisse dans l'endroit où il ya la
télévision elle est privé de télé et
tout d'un coup elle cherche son chat
partout voilà elle le cherche
évidemment il va le trouver dans la
pièce où il ya des télévisions aux
mamans il a l'air triste elle câline le
char et elle regarde la télévision
ç'a eu des enfants non plus voilà donc
ça c'est important effectivement être
d'accord ensemble et puis au niveau des
limites on n'explique pas tout on
n'explique pas un petit pourquoi on met
pas les besoins dans la prise
on lui explique pas pourquoi il faut pas
courir dans l'escalier je veux dire à un
moment donné on est là pour les protéger
on est là pour leur donner c'est ni
clairement un univers sécuritaire ya
rien de pire et de plus anxiogène qu'un
petit qui pensent qu'il ya des limites à
rien cela dit rassuré quand même tout le
monde la famille l'idéal n'existe pas
vous enfants l'idéal n'existe pas à ben
si jeune kate unique action et en plus
tout dépend les tranches d'âge on sait
si vous voulez faut être clair que pour
arriver à voir ce qu'on appelle la
pensée hypothético déductive va 19 22 23
un enfant il est pas en mesure de se
rendre compte que l'acte posé ici
donnera-t-elle conséquence c'est aux
parents effectivement de lui montrer ça
oui les parents toujours la référence
pour l'enfant qui est en construction
anna est finalement bien sûr c'est eux
qui donnent les codes comme l'expliqué
l'institutrice
et puis il ya un gros souci aussi elle
parlait des limites mais un problème sur
la concentration
ce sont effectivement des générations
qui sont extrêmement dispersé qui
partent dans tous les sens à partir du
moment où la frustration est au rendez
vous il ya une incapacité à sion
effectivement à se poser donc envisager
de poser l'enfance et comment il faut
aux états unis rapidement parce que je
me suis pas mal lutté aux états unis il
y à une chaise spécifique dédié où l'on
n'est pas au coin nous ou très mauvais
plan mais sur cette chaise on dit à
l'enfant voilà que tu vas rester dix
minutes et donc la famille vie devant
lui et il est à côté ça marche très bien
on